[Music]
today we're going to pets no we're not
garden center
oh my god we're going to the french
store i can't wait to go
i mean stuff for the house basically
let's go ikimasho
[Music]
from the third floor
get it
almost died how we doing
something about dogs
well we didn't press
floor
[Music]
hey look at me
look at that again
you can finally grow your veggies
mata is in heaven
dude
japan has sold the sink issue
that is so smart
look at them flying in there
that's so smart this shop is messy
having a good time maya
she's just chilling look at you
looking good guys i guess you're so
popular
you get so many kawaiis
how many countries have you gone maya
wow
i could guess them all yeah
you are so good
it's like a happiness
we're done shopping we got a lot of
great stuff
i got a
high pressure water thing so i can clean
yeah
i don't know if i said it but
everyone has a mask here i don't think
it's required anymore because of the
heat
it hasn't really gotten that hot yet but
everyone wears one and you get looks if
you don't wear one
so we're definitely wearing one
are you looking me again
what are you going to a dog cafe
checking it out
[Music]
[Music]
i'm adjusting my
so they have
so these are for dogs
oh my gosh
they get a pizza
sit
sit dirty
all right he got his pizza you want a
slice
i've never seen him hesitate so much
he's like
that's
yeah
look at this
for maya
if you don't want it i know someone
knows
the most spoiled dog in the world
apparently
you're having a good day maya
there's a stone there
girl
you made a mess
see
he doesn't know if you can eat it or not
again
okay
you're allowed to eat it
are you still behaving all the time
[Music]
i'm walking my uh
she's a little uh
crazy she's got the dementis as we call
it just at night she goes a bit crazy
sometimes
we try to keep her calm and relaxed but
uh we don't really know
it's just what happens with some old
dogs but it's definitely not
easy she needs a lot of attention she
kind of just goes crazy from six to nine
and then she just crashes like she falls
asleep
but until then she just like keeps
panting she keeps barking so
it's all right
we still love you
[Music]
first time on the freeway
i think we're gonna hit the tolls and i
have no idea what's about to happen
we figured it out in friends and smans
anyway we're going to see it enjoy
very exciting
rainy season beautiful days
everyone kept saying how hot japan is
it's not hot
i'm gonna survive better than anyone
this summer
everyone keeps thinking i'm a swede and
i can't handle it just wait cut back to
this later when i complain about the
heat which will never happen
[Music]
um
oh my god
that was very much a damn
that's so bitter
look at this
mine says cooking japanese with an
italian twist this is so good so we got
this tofu from our local shop that's
right we have a local tofu shop
we went and uh said hi to our neighbors
today
and we were so nervous at least i was
but it went great they were so lovely i
was a little
nervous because
you've heard stories about older people
in japan maybe they don't scared of
foreigners
but they were so lovely so
we gave them a little gift
thanks to tokidoki emma who helped us
pick a japanese present
i guess this is
the formality in japan you're supposed
to do that which makes sense gibson uh
gave us an opportunity to say hi to them
so that was good big step
yeah let's dig in
so crispy
yes
amazing
you're taking your cooking to another
level here
yes
oh thank you g fuel oh yes
oh
oh
[Music]
oh
i'm so happy
oh they'll never leave me again
oh station is great what are they saying
music of course
and now they knew they knew what flavors
are like
so my office is a mess right now
but i want to set up
by the way don't cancel me okay i'm just
gonna okay i'm working on it
anyway
i'm gonna set up a half power rack
i've always really wanted one
but i always i always felt like i never
had space for it i don't feel like i
have space for it still
but
i want it okay i want it i know it won't
look good in here like this is such a
pretty room i want it i want it i don't
care
if it looks aesthetic i just want it
[Music]
hello
back in the row
finally today we're going to see the
tesla
i feel like i've already made up my mind
about which car i want but i
feel like i should go and see it
so we'll see maybe i'm just sway
smooth
we're also maybe going to watch some
aquariums and hopefully
i really want to get our ginkgo or hanko
which is like a stamp that you use for
signatures here
uh which i will need if i buy a car
you need to do the little stamping i
hope i get to decide my own
i'm excited for it
we're going so deep
what has happened it keeps going round
where are we we're going to the center
of the earth
what is happening is this right
no one warned us about this
by the way uh you'll drive into hell
okay
cool
[Music]
we're in shinjuku
it's very hot
it's very
busy
we haven't really been to places that
are this busy it's kind of insane
honestly
just seeing all the big buildings and
everything what's it behind you
no one's ever made that joke
so pretty
this one's got smoke
these are so cool
i know mars has been
dreaming of a blowfish
for like 10 years
this one
very big brain
it's
cute
do you think they have a puffer fish
usually it's not okay to take a video
and photo in store but this one said you
can
they're cool
no puffers
oh they have them we're just looking
anyway
right
they're so cute
they're so tiny so this sign says
that it's popular with cute women
all right so if you want a cute girl
guys just get a puffer fish
oh my god a spy family
[Music]
let me guess the purple
i think this is the 3d looking one
but it doesn't really look 3d to me
oh no i'm shooting in the wrong frame
rate or frequency ah totally ruined it
there's so much going on
i'm just like what
this is too much for my swedish heart
i can't handle it
looks so cool it's nice looking
[Music]
that was really cool i got some motion
stick because they have like this
display
i kept looking at the display but i
really like the car it's
better than i thought
so now i'm kind of like hmm it's a
really
comfortable ride it has all these cool
features
they're very different from different
options i think
even my dad said that it's really ugly
everyone's making fun of this car online
today
hey
[Music]
[Music]
we're going to the vet
just to do a checkup
we haven't registered with the vet yet
so
um
yeah it's a cool location we found an
english-speaking one that seemed pretty
good we'll see how it goes
who's ready for the doctor
[Music]
does she have food
they have manga
it looks like you
right here
you guys were so good
well done guys
maya you got so many compliments
for being so old and healthy
what did she say
good muscle good muscle on my ass good
muscle
good weighing
still
time so has appetite
you're gonna break records man
no one cares about me
i'm like the middle child that no one
cares about
[Music]
what's up today i'm building furniture
unleashing my swedish powers
but it's a god damn mess they sent me
the wrong package for my power rack so i
had to write them in my epic nihongo and
i think they got it but yeah i'm
building a shelf
it's gonna go there i've spent every
a ridiculous amount of time trying to
figure out this room and how i want it
so this better be good but yeah before
we'll do before and then hopefully after
take two
i'm gonna try and get our bank account
today
we're going in personally
face to face do i look proper
everyone says getting the bank account
is the hardest part of uh the japanese
residency thing so
fingers crossed
we already failed
so we entered and was like oh do you
speak english
and uh they were just like no
we were like but we looked online it
said you speak english we need to go to
the other one across the road
i can't run in these shoes
all right
take three people got so mad that i said
i didn't speak any japanese like i know
a little bit and i have studied a lot
it's just that
when you ask someone here if they speak
japanese
sorry if they speak english
they'll go like oh squishy
like a little but then they speak
fluently so if you say you speak a
little that means you're fluent so
that's why if someone asks me if i speak
japanese it's like
no
even though i do know a little bit so
yeah just addressing the haters nihongo
josu okay
i got this
we failed
we needed a certificate from our company
because we've been here less than
six months it's a little annoying but
hey what can you do we'll uh we'll get
it next time yeah we kind of don't know
what to do now we have the day free
we might just [ __ ] around
i wanted to end this vlog with the high
you want to buy a bike
they have so much cool stuff here
look at that bad boy
we ended up going shopping this day
it's tough out there this look
professionally
very nice
oh boy what a long day it's fun though i
like these days where normally you would
call it a quint halfway through but it's
like no keep going got more stuff to do
i'm trying to figure out my desk
so i couldn't find a desk big enough
here
uh so i got two desks
that i'm gonna put
together i got some brackets on amazon
so hopefully this will work i don't know
how i got so indecisive
i swear i used to just like go for [ __ ]
and be like that's fine
but i think so many times you order
stuff and then it's the wrong size and
yeah whatever same with the car like i'm
still debating the car like should i get
a tesla but i it's really cool and
comfortable but i really want a japanese
car
uh will it suit you know tokyo and by
the way it's a very good problem to have
not being able to pick a car and i like
kind of dragging it out a little bit
because then it's like
more satisfying when you do make the
choice knowing yeah i made the right
choice you know i thought about it i
considered all the options
it's holding
how am i gonna flip it what's that
with the strength of marshall we got it
damn it's massive
i think it'll look really good once it's
all cleaned up
i've always wanted to have a huge desk
it totally holds
so yeah i couldn't put any feet here
because then obviously
if you slide in like this it's not gonna
work so
they did the trick
yes huge desk
so big
i
love it here
so much
it feels so good to be here honestly i'm
so glad thanks for coming along and uh
yeah hopefully i can do a setup tour
once this is all set up until then